c'est mardi 23 novembre l'antenne locale
des restos du coeur de plaisir a rouvert
ses portes pour sa campagne hivernale la
situation
chez avec ma fille et le resto mais
donne là le resto mais dans des aides
dont vu la rue mais si chaque moment me
l'a dit mais si la situation de cette
plaisir oise n'est pas un cas isolé de
nombreuses mères célibataires sont
présentes dans la file d'attende de
cette antenne yvelinoise avec la crise
sanitaire et la crise du pouvoir d'achat
le centre s'attend également à voir
s'inscrire de nouvelles familles
bénéficiaires dans les prochains jours
il faut savoir que les profils qu'on a
là de la période d'yves qu'on inscrit en
été en hiver là c'est toutes nos
familles de cet été donc si vous voulez
les nouveaux profils vont arriver un peu
plus tard avec 40 % d'augmentation
d'inscriptions depuis un an dont 2 fois
plus de bébés la cinquantaine de
bénévoles sert plusieurs milliers de
repas chaque semaine les chiffres qui
pourraient exposer cet hiver selon les
responsables du centre l'année dernière
on a fini la campagne d'hiver avec 300
familles et là on redémarre la campagne
d'hiver déjà avec 180 familles donc je
pense qu'on va avoir une progression
tout au long de l'année et qu'on finit
ce mois de mars sûrement avec plus de 3
plus de 350 femmes il ya des grandes
chances en france les restos du coeur
ont servi près de 1,5 million de repas
l'hiver dernier